a lot has been made a lot has been said
a lot has been suggested about
the sentences that are coming down or
being handed down or the manner with
which the january 6 insurrectionists are
being treated in federal jail
there is no federal bail system
um like there is in state courts or
local municipalities it's either you're
you're you're released on your own
recognizance or you're put on
house arrest with an ankle monitor or
you're uh remanded to custody until
trial
and a federal judge
this is a political headline
judge suggests feds are too lenient
toward january 6 defendants the chief
judge at the federal court in washington
raised questions about why pleading
guilty to a misdemeanor was permitted to
resolve certain cases
now
many of you don't know who i am but i
happen to have a close connection
to the january 6 insurrection my wife
and uh co-host of my podcast i doubt it
one of them
this dingus
was my wife's high school boyfriend i
just
i just got in the way i just got in the
capitol building
i was the first one i hopped down in the
chamber and i was the first one to sit
and nancy pelosi
that [ __ ]
her hat her she's she's a traitor she's
treasonous
save the condolences
this was a long time ago it's not like
she escaped some culty relationship they
were kids
but this is the kind of of of people
that i was surrounded by growing up in
idaho
josiah colt who also related to this
story is being allowed all kinds of
plea deals for his promises to
turn states uh evidence and and testify
against his uh conspirators
there are absolutely deals being made
and i think this judge
has uh an important perspective a
federal judge suggested monday that
federal prosecutors were being too
lenient in their handling of cases
stemming from the storming of the united
states capital as lawmakers were
convening on january 6 to certify joe
biden's victory in the presidential race
beryl howell the chief judge of the
federal court in washington deluged with
more than 550 prosecutions from the
capitol riot raised questions about why
some defendants were being permitted to
resolve their criminal cases by pleading
guilty to a misdemeanor and why the
amount of money prosecutors are seeking
to recover through those plea deals was
based on a relatively paltry estimate of
about 1.5 million in damages caused by
the rioters
howell aired her doubts during what was
expected to be a routine morning hearing
to take the guilty plea of a capital
riot defendant glenn croy of colorado
springs colorado
croy was arrested in february on charges
that he and another men terry lindsey
illegally entered the capitol building
on january 6th
final paragraph here under a deal with
prosecutors kroy was seeking to plead
guilty to a single misdemeanor charge of
parading or picketing in the capital
that carries a maximum sentence of six
months in jail and a fine of up to five
thousand
to overuse a term again this does not
pass the smell test they weren't just
their picketing it wasn't a protest they
weren't holding a parade
the intent of everyone there who entered
the capital was to disrupt the counting
of votes the certification
of the 2020 presidential election
to overturn
those results
to strike and stoke fear in a
terroristic manner
into the hearts and minds of of
legislators
tasked with constitutionally tasked with
certifying the vote
electing in a peaceful transfer of power
the next president of the united states
so i'm with
barrel howell i agree
hard questions need to be asked as we
delve into
these particular prosecutions they
shouldn't prosecutors should not be too
too quick to allow plea deals
that will
lighten the results and the consequences
for these insurrectionists